what's up guys Greg in the hizzy drag
what's your name
Arianna I'm just so excited to call you
guys thank you thank you
Arianna knows I'm not as much of a
pervert in real life just a little bit
just like minuscule I'm gonna try to not
make boob jokes yep porn star porn star
couple reacts to each other's porn this
is great this sounds interesting I love
it I love porn star couples I love the
idea of this that's so weird
I recently stopped watching porn a few
weeks ago I know and one of my favorite
porn stars is asa Akira
Asian girl and she met her husband from
doing a DP see double penetration that's
what that stands for yeah cool yeah I
mean a lot of porn stars date other porn
stars I feel like because that makes the
most sense because they understand yeah
yeah I wouldn't that be kind of cool to
like data points are I thought it would
be kind of cool like if I ever had sex
with a porn star to like watch one of
her pornos while I'm having sex with you
could just film yourself having sex with
anyone no I'd rather watch like what
she's done with other people yeah like
I'd be comparing myself I'm not like in
love with this porn so do you have any
favorite porn stars um I like Stoia
yoshi is she's like very pale I just
like her I call her on history she's
very like feminist political actually
she dated James Dean the porn actor yes
yes who I saw them together one really
yeah yeah well James Dean's now bad guy
felon you know rape allegations ya know
don't get into it but I saw them
together when they're still together and
I was with Emily my most conservative
friend and I was like do you think James
Dean's hot no really but he's a pasadena
jew is he yeah so you know I do like the
Jews it looks like it was a great scene
like she enjoyed it so maybe if you [ __ ]
me yes
I'll give you a higher rating okay hi
what's up everybody I'm here today with
my favorite porn stars in the whole
world
chuckling Taylor Justin Jones and you
guys see them nice penis [ __ ]
never watch his pork and we're gonna see
how Jacqueline feels about this so she's
she's getting choked you choking her
have it's all pleasure do you guys like
to do I mean yeah I was like yeah who
took me at homes makes me kind of wish
he would like bring a little [ __ ] like
this home for me what a girl
I get very lucky man no this is what I'm
done scenes with these girl I don't [ __ ]
when you just finish the scene or
whatever do you come home like you said
you don't really you guys does a great
work piece of work do you come home and
that you're like I just had the best
[ __ ] day at work anything on who he
works where they tell him not to watch
this dick off and then just come home
and [ __ ] me sometimes you do and I can
actually taste it look I'm fraction are
you if you are I'm gonna kill you wait
you speak French yeah can you say like
[ __ ] that dirty [ __ ] in French yeah you
say it dude some quick advice on there
that's my [ __ ] right there looks at me
there's an ad on all my friends back
home like where we can't jerk off
anymore we just watched Jessie seen what
looks like it was a great scene looks
like she enjoyed it so I mean maybe if
you [ __ ] me Mia's more I'll give you a
higher he's such a dick
[Music]
if I can just the game's girls well lit
oh it's lit this was a funny scene
though like the people after that rented
us this house were like complaining
because we got come on their shoes
somebody came that's a collision like
get a [ __ ] life you're taking it good
there how can you take it back she can I
mean worst night of her life she just
goes to set put a little Lube on that
puts the engine she takes it that's
teamwork
there's no there's no like right now my
heart is a little broken well it's
pretty good that I swallowed that so I'm
happy to see that fun yeah I come home
and I'm like all babe that goes terrible
[ __ ] I'm so happy yes music yeah because
he was good I know suppose not all of
that ball [ __ ]
all right well real quick on to say
thanks for pornhub for making this video
happen okay make sure you're subscribed
to my youtube channel simple sexist
stupid so you can see my weekly video
subscribe to simple sexist
Wow gosh wow that's
we know someone no no he knows someone
who is telling me how he's seriously
wanting to get into porn you know I'm
talking about who do we know who
probably didn't know before yeah he does
like cars shortest fanuc yeah and I
think it's perfect for him he's kind of
getting older we're all the same I'm too
old to do porn no you're not yeah I
watch a lot of documentaries and things
about porn and like you have to start at
18 well you could be like you know a
finish yeah I don't if I'm already
getting auditions for like young mom are
you really yeah oh wow
I mean but your body looks great you're
like you're in great shape if you were
in a porno I would skim through it but
I'm done before and done with form okay
because your dollop because I'm done
with more if I was into porn heavily
still I would gladly watch it but now
this is kind of like a guy's dream right
here
you don't mean a lot of girls who like
would want something like that but
there's a lot of guys out there who
would be like oh that's so cool that my
girlfriend's into like other women yeah
real life it was probably jealous yeah
if it was me it's like would that be
cool if my girlfriend was like you could
have sex with other girls sure but if
she had sex with another guy do feel
happy there's such a double standard a
cool
but if you were there if I was there
maybe you know like I have thought about
like when it comes a Devils Devils trio
what the call if I had a Devils trio I
would not do it with someone I'm
romantically involved with I would have
to yeah I think any kind of threesome it
would have to be with another non-roma
yeah exactly you want to be the stranger
like I've met girls who are you know
who've said like well I could do stuff
with the girl but you can't you know
like girls will get like particularly
about that and I I feel like that would
get me jealous that would get you
jealous yeah cuz like why can you kiss
her and I can't kiss yeah especially if
my girls like bisexual lightning how do
I put this if the girl just likes to
mess around with girls like just for fun
maybe but if she like has like bisexual
to the point where she can like get
romantic yeah it would like it would
like my beyond something for you yeah
together I just I mean are these guys
like really like in love with each other
you think that's impossible to know yeah
the more people are like obsessed with
their boyfriend or girlfriend like the
left in love I read something about it
the more people post on Facebook we're
out their relationship the more like
insecure they are about that that makes
sense cuz they're looking for
gratification and they're showing how in
love they are and maybe these guys are
the most in love couple in the world
hmm and you just there's Joe like that
yeah I would like to see one of the
reporters look see the guy but very easy
to do that really think so you type in
their name no what do you get enter like
I'm sure it will take you straight to
their website
that's not how I've got important store
buy the magazines videotapes one of my
friends have been Playboy this one ooh
Brooke shout-out Brooke Brooke what
howard rick powell it's gone
Brooke power what she look like she's
Hawaiian she's super hot here I'll show
you her Instagram oh cool post us on our
walls that she knows
I see Brooke powers what's going on
name's Greg Brooke power yeah oh yeah
she is gorgeous
yep I went to a party recently and I met
this couple that was there and the guy
works at a swingers resort resort yeah
like you actually go as a couple
yeah came on E and then I mean they have
like sex parties like that that's crazy
have you been to one yeah I did not
participate I also have a joke about
that she's promoting her stand-up I did
go and I like had a fake name for myself
and everything and I guess you saw like
people having none so I get there and
immediately felt like see someone I went
to college with who like calls me out
and I've never seen anyone having sex
really never seen you in person like in
person never actually seen someone have
sex
Zachary really I was that kind of hot
I don't know I'm becoming more emotional
these days and word out you know
companionship until already honest
Tucker talking about them that just
changed
I cried so hard to be an active
participant and I just threw up I'm
sorry
every time I try to do anything
adventures I throw up hey guys you can
subscribe today to become a reject
Ariana badassery what are we talking
about for you today my Instagram I have
a Facebook fan page with not that many
fans yeah well she needs more fans it's
important I started my fashion blog
fashion blog yeah I was looking through
that a lot today teracle thing no it's a
real fashion blog where ariana is really
showing her passionate side she's a
model she's a model
give me bikini photos on there I've only
started the blog like a week ago so not
until I get in a bikini fine I have them
on Instagram I'm more than that
arianna I know you're more than that is
just sex cells it's a category you know
sex is one of the many categories you
guys you know I made my Instagram on
private do you think that's better yeah
you'll get more followers well I didn't
know if I'd get more followers because
they have to like be my follower they
just can't see it for nothing
no yeah now they're gonna follow you and
especially cuz they're gonna see your
photos are gonna be like oh this woman's
gorgeous and then they're gonna that
works gorgeous yes oh wow that's what
happens when you